according to a new study soldiers with
PTSD using the illegal drug known as
MDMA or ecstasy cured the condition
within weeks this is key because I don't
think I've ever seen the word cured in a
highfalutin medical journal usually it's
significantly improves but never cures
now the study was small 26 patients but
the message is big when a substance has
a real effect meaning it changes you it
also frightens people drugs like ecstasy
are illegal because they work and when
things work
they are hijacked for other purposes to
have fun for example and then people die
from taking too much and that's when the
law breaks in in bands it this has
happened to many substances that could
have helped millions of people just
decades ago MDMA showed real promise in
psychotherapy then it got banned but
times are changing we realize it's
absurd to punish a substance and a
patient because the substance has
potential for abuse instead let
scientists test them on various hard to
treat illnesses you want a crazy example
try botulinum toxin it's a substance
that's deadly yet instead of reporting
its lethality newscasters shoot it into
their faces because it reduces wrinkles
when used wisely it's poison
other drugs like Special K are now being
tested on depression pots also being
tried on PTSD as well so with scientific
study comes progress and relief so why
not send a drug down that path instead
of leaving it on the street
alright you know what I think is smart
Dana if you look at a lot of these
studies it's the choice of the patient
if you use veterans people have an
innate sense Democrats and Republicans
that we owe it to them yeah so it's a
great strategy like if you just did this
is a study of depressed IT workers no
one's people going to ask too bad no
because also we've we have thankfully
learn enough about pts that your
computer's never getting fixed yeah
sorry IT workers I think we've learned
enough about pts to understand just how
damaging it is to somebody and have the
terror the or especially also the
suicides yes okay so yeah
I agree with this one thing I think the
could happen because of this study and
the concern about it being misused and
abused it's the possibility of new
delivery devices so for example right if
you find out that it's something that
works for a patient with PTSD of a
veteran is there something that can
implant yeah something that where the
doctor is in charge of it it's not
something that's like handing pills out
on the street right and there's a lot of
new innovations like that happening and
Scott Gottlieb who is the FDA
Commissioner under President Trump is
really forward-thinking in this regard
so it's possible that something could
actually happen
I hope so one they're looking at all
sorts of drugs that we've always been
taught in the 70s like when we used to
watch dragnet remember every drug was
bad acid every but now they're all
looking at these things because they see
they have potential for many illnesses
yeah I mean marijuana is at the cutting
edge of this and it's again it's it's
older people who find it's good for pain
relief relaxation and I think it's lots
of people who are voters and so I think
you've seen the country change on
marijuana in a radical way in our
lifetime while they're voting explain
November 2016 more pot all right
but you know what struck me was I
thought when I first read this I think
oh boy right this is not you know what
this is like some big pharmaceutical
companies come up to get through the
story and says no not at all this is
Association for psychedelic studies
rights which was created in 1986 after
MDMA or ecstasy had been banned exact so
I don't know so then I thought was so
were these people
supporters of ecstasy is that why they
were created I think that there was a
group of psychotherapists who were
really really angry when they were a
valuable tool was taken from them and I
can't remember the guy who's in charge
do Burren I think it'll do blur I can't
think of the guy's name but he's been
pioneering all of this and but it's
that's that's how it happened they were
ticked off that the government stepped
in and but you know it's interesting to
me that you know previously what most
concerns would have said oh no
absolutely no no no but now given the
veterans needs that's because it's a
crisis for the veterans all of a sudden
the concerns like oh yeah I think that's
that was the key I think Kimberly what
do you yeah I
you know this is part of the overall you
know complex problem that we have facing
veterans those that are coming home so
many more of them surviving injuries
otherwise that would have been life
threatening or ending in TBI traumatic
brain injury the depression anxiety the
homelessness the things that come with
serving being away families broken up
it's it's very difficult but I think
there is definitely a genuine interest
in trying to do the best for men and
women that serve and part of that would
be allowing them maybe exposure to some
other different types of remedies or
drugs or therapies that might be
beneficial to them so many of them can
seeking of the help of the VA as a you
know a last resort I think that's why we
really need to do something about it and
put in somebody very strong and great
there to do a wonderful job for the
veterans and really help them you know
just did you ever think you'd be doing a
pro ecstasy segment on Fox News LSD was
used in the forties in the 50s in the
60s in small clinical trials to treat
alcoholism and PTSD and depression and
then it was banned because people would
abuse it and now it's getting a second
look because of this the brain scanning
imagery is so much more detailed you can
see if it's MDMA or a small dosage of
LSD what effect that has on the brain
and it gives the scientists and the
medical professional is a more accurate
read on what it's actually accomplishing
I think every option should be on the
table if it's a therapy dog if it's
psychotherapy hyperbaric chambers
medical marijuana MDMA let's get it all
fixed and something that's taboo
shouldn't prevent doctors from Rhonda I
know but I just don't want ecstasy can
kill young people they go to these
parties range trial you know well no
that's good that's important you don't
want people to get the wrong idea about
it but it just goes to show you once
again if the men and women that serve
that are the bravest to try other
remedies and treatments are gonna help
other people right exactly what would
you do for your family member that's the
point you know
exactly